we have our keynote speaker Smith
chantella is a VP at meta a and the
co-creator of pytorch a major scientific
Computing framework within the a AI
Community let's give Smith a warm
welcome it's a very early morning for me
I usually wake up at 10:30 or so so
thanks for listening to me uh half
asleep um but more seriously uh I was
asked to give a keynote and whenever I'm
asked to give a keynote I have no idea
what to say because apparently Keynotes
are supposed to not be normal talks
you're supposed to try to say something
insightful and like I have very less
very little insightful things to say so
um I thought I'll actually pick a simple
topic um I think the Rel relatability of
this topic will be varied among all of
you uh if you're an advanced user of AI
and AI tools uh then you're going to
find this talk
Elementary uh if you're not then you're
going to find this talk maybe a little
inside but maybe you're going to like
learn a couple of things so uh apologies
to those people who already uh know
everything that I'm going to talk about
and uh let's get started so I want to
try to bridge
um Two Worlds like if you're a data
scientist or if you support data
scientist data scientists uh or data
Engineers or data analysts I didn't
forget you all um
the question comes up
um oh there's this AI thing uh and
there's these AI tools like you know
when are they useful for us right so I I
just want to try to bridge the
understanding and GAP and when they
might be useful for uh general practice
of data science and so in my
understanding my wife's a data scientist
um so if my understanding is wrong blame
my wife right so uh my understanding is
um um data scientists is
mostly trying to make like help you make
decisions using data uh in a very robust
and scientific way um we versus AI is oh
you put some input into a model and like
came out a prediction and uh in very
limited cases within the field of AI you
think about
robustness um so like obviously I needed
a meme where you know someone is like
hey I need to find out what's wrong with
the factory slowing down and someone
says let's use deep learning and someone
says oh let's use AGI and then the one
pork says oh you know you should just
carefully look at the data and root cost
what the problem is and he just gets
thrown up that's where we are as of
today where everyone's just like ai ai I
mean like you look at the number of
times AI is used by every Tech CEO
including like probably a lot of our
employers and you kind of see the hype
and also I I think like it's not some
not their fault in that because like AI
is getting so popular a lot of customers
businesses who are more traditional who
don't really understand technology they
are understanding the word Ai and being
like well I heard AI is cool uh tell me
more so it's roughly what's happening so
um but robust data science is very
different from what people are calling
Ai and uh that's my understanding um um
and so in AI uh just to bridge the world
to people mostly who work in data
science a lot of research progress has
happened on oh it seems to work great
let's publish it and then let's use it
in the real world in many cases and
um this has actually helped make
progress um I kid you not like we
basically come from hm these pictures
don't look that good yet uh let's just
publish the method anyway it's a good
start to like slowly progressing towards
oh my God this model is generating these
amazing images no idea how or why or
what whatever right so um it
is I would say a very clearly an
experimental
science um in it's purest form so um but
like to be to be very clear it works uh
like progress in AI has been made in a
lot of places where verifiability of
whether something is working is not
related to uh some abstract thing but
it's actually grounded uh very likely in
human capabilities so generating images
videos text um even in the
non-generation cases like classifying um
uh detecting where things um as long as
they're grounded in some real world
process of some sort or uh reasonably
well understood human um uh human
capabilities then uh progress has been
made where you need more robust analysis
like for example like in um let's say
like in Radiology or you know something
like where like you actually need to um
um have explainability you need to have
have a robust understanding of why the
AI predicted something we haven't
actually made that much progress like
yes like people have published AI models
they're like oh this is like better than
like um expert doctors at X but like
mostly it has been fluff because if you
actually look in practice it turns out
it's not robust in a way that uh can be
integrated into Human Society where
Radiologists like do their work uh or
like other kinds of doctors there's like
many uh papers now where they put in
a um and like from my understanding um
and very limited from My Wife and a few
friends uh data science uh practically
typically I'm not saying all cases but
it's much smaller data volume uh you're
producing insights around processes and
dynamics of a system like a business or
like the government or you know
something like that and is there bad
data science of course um where is the
me
oh yeah um it's like there is that data
science where people make elaborate
narratives um versus actually um
actually providing scientific insights
and letting people take decisions um and
those people sometimes are called
expensive Consultants
right so um I
joke so uh this is like L like my
understanding of where things are in
terms of AI and in terms of data science
and so I'll talk a little bit about AI
tools that um that data scientists might
want to know as hey they exist where are
they useful and my goal here is to
mainly not educate you on what AI tools
exist but how to approach the problem
like hey when is like this AI tool
useful for me as a data scientist or not
um so um I helped build pych and so I'm
obviously going to have a few slides on
pych and do my job right so pych is like
naai uh but with different Origins it
actually originated from like Lua and
C++ and Objective C and you know like
all kinds of like random things um but
it is very much like numai um in in many
ways except a few API differ and they're
a compatible delayer um it enables about
600 ,000 uh Plus open source projects um
it uh is probably the most popular tool
in AI research by a large amount I think
we see like 60% of AIR research papers
use PGE and the clo second Clos this
tool um is like 5% market share so it's
reasonably popular um and it Powers the
AI industry as well we see this in like
number of people adver advertising for
like pip Works jobs and stuff
and um our forums do get very popular um
we get about 2,000 posts a month and um
it's very fun trying to like support
everyone at that that that scale um if
you want to understand any of uh the
stuff like P or anything you can find me
later today I'm happy with chat if you
you I see like in this conference
there's a lot of like open source um um
Builders who build their own tool so I'm
happy to chat with many things so um so
how does pyro come into data science and
maybe help well as of the latest vers of
py which we Rel last month um we are we
p is a compiler to make things faster
both on the CPU and the GPU and uh we
added numpy compatibility so like you
can not even know py toch like just you
have never touched ptor you don't know
what it is just pip install torch and
then you with on your numpy code just
add to add torch start compile similar
to
number um it produces uh reasonably fast
code uh the nice thing is um it also
allows you to um uh integrate uh if you
have a GPU you can actually have an
unire code seamlessly run on the GPU
without again having to know anything
about the GPU um it can trace through
arbitrary n code and whenever it doesn't
know what to do it will just fall back
to using n so it's like fairly robust in
giving you the right thing and for
example here's like you know you write a
k means u in numpy and then you just
compile it and uh on the CPU it's just
faster but then numpy uh after you
compile it by 57 times obviously this is
a toy example um but like your mileage
may vary and um you can actually
seamlessly use the GPU here is like um
showing how you basically write a tiny
on of like you know additional couple
lines and then suddenly the F becomes
GPU ready and um you get like 200 times
speed up and uh here's some micro
benchmarks that um um Mario from quanite
uh did and uh doing LDA like the LDA
from um I think like it was from
sapai um and they just saw that like as
soon as you added the py Tor compile on
it it just became dramatically faster on
the CPU as and even more faster on the
GPU so if you have a data science code
that seems to be running slow um most
likely it's your fault because you're a
bad
code there are chances that we might
help if your bad code is not so bad that
even our compiler can't understand
um so uh the other tool I want to talk
about is Jack it's actually um a very
straightforward um um reimplementation
of NPI it basically remaps numai API to
the xcla compiler uh by Google and it
also targets gpus and tpus and I
conveniently just screenshotted Matt
Johnson's talk on YouTube uh to save
myself and creating an actual slide but
Matt Johnson is uh the lead developer of
Jack uh the idea there is uh similar to
torch. compile that I showed you earlier
Jax has a couple of things like uh jit
and and pmap uh and basically you can
just jit your like numpy function and
it'll just Trace through uh your numpy
function and it will uh compile it and
you get a function and then you can run
it and it'll run much faster than base
NPI um so uh Jax is also uh fairly uh
seamless to you especially for um data
science stuff now the caveat on in pitor
and Ja and all of that is obviously like
um we did not build this stuff for data
science we built it for AI so our our um
our support for um data frames is a
fairly limited P which has a thing
called n 10 and jacket tensor and like
you know they can do stuff uh and we
have a thing called torch arrow that
interfaces P into like Arrow data frames
which you know pandas data frames can
convert into so there is a plumbing work
done uh and uh Jax also has very limited
support for U data frame like things but
where it is right and where like you're
clearly I think like to give Sound
Advice um let's say you have a
data science organization that's fairly
large and you have a bunch of
proprietary um functions or pipelines
that you run very frequently and you
want to speed those up because at some
reasonable scale you uh you get those
benefits then you can look into maybe uh
using py Jacks to write those parts to
get speed UPS across your organization I
think that would be um probably one of
one of the clearest ways in which you
get benefits from using AI tools uh but
ad H you can also like try and
uh pick up these skills so that you can
uh use um these tools when you feel like
uh even if your data science work it's
likely
to okay uh then obviously I said gpus
well pip and Jacks like really got
popular because they support gpus and
and eventually gpus well like okay gpus
cool what's the fundamental value
proposition why do AI people go down
about
gpus uh and why did Nvidia stock price
go up so much why didn't we
buy um so uh first is gpus are parallel
processors so they do faster parallel
processing and second is they have
higher memory bandwidth if you want to
basically do some operation you need to
for Shuffle it uh from memory into the
CPU and do some operation and then put
it back into memory whe uh and similarly
if if you're doing it on GPU you take it
from memory put it onto the GPU um from
Main memory put it on GPU register and
then put it back in the GPU main memory
now gpus can move memory much faster
than CPUs can because the kind of memory
and the kind of blocking uh of the
memory is uh just makes it higher
bandwidth
so if generally just by definition of
what I said if you're not doing tiny
workloads where you're like doing an
operation over four elements or 10
elements if you're if you have like say
10,000 data points or so um and anything
about that then actually by design your
GPU is going to be faster at doing
everything um versus the CPU unless
you're doing very branchy operations
like so GPS are not very good at not
being parallel if you try to do
sequential stuff um on such a massive
parallel processor it will just be
slower than your CPU is going to be so
that's like how you can think of where
you really want to use gpus and where
you like shouldn't be thinking about
using
gpus um Nvidia actually wrote a data
science package for gpus called uh not
ecosystem called Rapids um and I'm sure
most of the room already knows this but
it was something if I didn't put it'll
look odd okay all right so the second
topic I want to talk about is the hot
stuff right like these days AI llms oh
my God GPT it's
amazing okay so uh my goal here is to
try to give you all a mental model of
where you should be using LMS and how
you should be using them and where you
shouldn't be using them like that's
really my uh end goal
so I want to help you build a mental
model on LMS first I will tell you uh
one uh one way to build a mental model
um so think of llms as like a like you
have unlimited maybe a thousand limited
intelligence large knowledge
good and eloquent communicators trying
to help you so they are of limited
intelligence uh so if you for example
are trying to give them a task that is
that requires reasoning especially
Advanced reasoning anything more than
basic reasoning they will not work they
will be very eloquent they will be very
good at communicating back you that they
have found an effective solution and
that they're going to give you a whole
line of reasoning on why the answer is
correct but it's going to be exactly
like when you went to an exam in I don't
know I did in eth grade and I didn't
know the answer and I made up I was
like I will write some answer and then I
will work backwards to how this answer
can feel like correct I want to P my
t-shirt that's like I mean llm the the
the their objective function is to just
like predict an answer that you think
looks right not that is actually
grounded to being right so uh that is
the first thing so um they so like the
reason like I give you this analogy is
because now you know which parts of uh
your day-to-day workflow you can
automate and you cannot automate the
second thing uh I want to tell you is
there are other ways in which you your
your guards are on go down so
because LMS are often offered as a chat
interface and we over the last three
decades have used chat interface to talk
to other humans we basically like think
the llm is a human like you know our
guards around like you know calling out
go down a little bit um and so
that is another additional bias we have
to anthom anthrop for
the the word is what
anthropomorphizing llms or just like
pretending that they're humans um so the
third thing is like there's actually
like UI tricks that make you feel like
another human is typing like these are
all tricks now now like if you take a
basil LM and you're like okay I typed a
question wait for 30 seconds and wait
for the whole answer and then you you
read the answer you're like okay like
you actually like you can try the
experiment but you will actually um
believe it less than like if you like
get it in this like type like you know
type ahead interface so um there's a lot
of product building that was done uh and
the objective function of the llms like
llms are basically like like this cat as
soon as you see this cat you know it's a
cat but you're like oh man this is like
an intelligent cat
because you have this bias towards oh if
some like you know we like oh if this
person's more well-dressed and the
person must be like some important or
like intelligent or well educated or
something this is a bias we have uh and
if I put a cat in there you still have
that bias and it's the same bias that
kicks in when um when lm's and you
interact with each other so um
so uh where to use them so stuff that
you know but you don't remember so if
you're like oh I forgot how to plot this
kind of thing again and you need to
Google but then you need to Google and
then search like 20 links to find the
exact answer actually llms are much
better at like giving the right like
they're like good solid pattern matchers
they are able to those those
thousand um dogs are searching on the
internet for the exact answer and then
like putting like putting your situation
into those answer and seeing if it works
out and giving you like a very eloquent
answer um so what is this yeah so it
doesn't know when the answer is wrong
and so you need to know so you need like
you can use them as assistance But
ultimately I can tell you like do not
try to automate them um um yet because
um that's basically how you can have a
production failure and probably lose a
lot of money um and definitely don't use
it for anything like human critical
don't put in put in like um like saving
lives or
anything um all right so you can use it
to accelerate your workflow but not to
actually automate you in fact I can
convince you that uh I myself am not
convincing tell you that I myself have
become more productive using llms
yesterday I was writing a research paper
and um actually like uh we we were
co-authoring a research paper one of my
students uh wrote an introduction it
looked good in terms of content but it
just was not the right English it just
you know like it just didn't come out
right I just gave it to Chad I'm like
rewrite the same thing but like more
eloquently and it was
fantastic I cannot tell you how much
better it was than if I could have
written it so there are things that it
does well that you should use it for but
be be aware of where it doesn't do well
you can use it for brainstorming it's
like a Google search but better uh you
can use it maybe for Baseline work
actually chadd now has this like code
interpreter that lets you do basic data
analysis and data science it will do
some some amount of work that amounts to
like like using a bunch of stack
Overflow like Snippets and then throwing
your code into it and see seeing what
happens uh searching for personalized
answers but faster it's like a more
effective Google search as I said uh
where you don't have to search for
similar situation as yours by going to a
bunch of links and being like Oh my God
like user 4567 what did you know that I
like you know why didn't you reply back
for the answer you know like uh so that
kind of stuff um you like every has done
like oh yeah I've Googled an hour for
the answer like this is like standard
answer for people over the last decade
or two right um that Googling for an
hour can become oh I asked chat GPD and
it found the right answer and there are
products like perplexity uh B uh Bing
search that
augment uh llms with retrieval so that
the amount of scope the llms have to
hallucinate an answer versus like like
having citations where you can actually
go click through or so it's more limited
in the way it can give a wrong answer so
they're more effective um in terms of
you having a productive um um productive
uh use of
that um so uh you can actually again
like I want to repeat like you can get
fooled by like some someone like someone
was like oh you asked G draw a uniforn
in tick which is like this you know ltic
like language right ltic diagram
language and it's like oh draw a unicorn
it must be so intelligent because it's
starting to like like do all kinds of
like no one has like drawn a unicorn it
takes before and like it's able to do
that which means it understands the body
of a unicorn and it's able to map it to
like latex diagram language it turns out
there's people on the internet who build
like animals and
l so and it is definitely using that as
training data and I've seen the training
data for these LMS it's all kinds of
crazy I mean like the internet is vast
and like I don't think we as humans by
default comprehend it and it's really
important to understand that a lot of
stuff exists and don't get fooled on
knowledge versus reasoning like the the
the
difference um and there's like an actual
website which keeps doing this every day
it's like okay like if I asked you to
draw unicorn and Tak what did it give me
today and every day it's like
different
so um and then there's actual scientific
papers that actually out that even on
basic reasoning problems like L don't do
well and there's a lot of people who
might think oh you know I read this
article that says if you ask it this is
incorrect like you know do uh try one
more time or like think about it very
carefully and give me an answer if you
use those terms then llms will get more
accurate and it turns out that was
it was just like selection bias
a lot of people post like the best
things on the internet and they will
ignore the worst things and so these
guys in data way showed that if you
actually critique it uh or prompt it in
a slightly better way it actually gets
worse um so um anyways uh and then
there's diffusion models the hot thing
around generating images and videos and
stuff uh there's not much scope for
using it in data science you can make
talks like this all the images like not
all but like some of the images I won't
tell you which ones I used um
GPT uh uh you can make memes you can
make stuff up like for example I just
made this plot that you know if my boss
asked for something and they want to
pretty report but they I know they maybe
they did like not my boss sorry someone
else let's say like they don't actually
look at the fs ever then it was amazing
all right that's it on my side thank
[Applause]
you